johnny depp is his ex amber heard in
talks to write a multi-million dollar
revenge book you know i made a lot of
mistakes
a lot of mistakes but i've always told
the truth
a source tells e.t amber is confident
that her side will come out eventually
and she has a plan and strategy to make
a comeback over the next year this was
the most humiliating and horrible thing
i've ever been through i have never felt
more
removed from my own humanity
the tell-all would make sense amber is
financially strapped she also has kept a
love journal documenting her volatile
relationship with johnny and was
frequently seen taking notes in court as
for johnny who sported a goatee
throughout the trial he's got a mini
makeover
clean shaven in all smiles the 59 year
old was spotted greeting even hugging
and kissing fans in finland he's
currently on a world tour with buddy
jeff beck
but it seems johnny is still fighting to
save his name depp posted that he's been
made aware of fake accounts pretending
to be me and warned fans to remain
cautious he says i do not have any
private or side accounts on any
platforms
[Music]